helping Clark County students get to
college and get degrees it is the sole
purpose of a new program students can
really benefit from so this is open to
high school students who come from
certain economic background
are the first and their families to go
to college 8 news now reporter Joshua
paguero explains how it works
Nevada state college officials say they
work on eradicating poverty and one way
they do that is to throw a lot of
resources at it to make sure that each
impoverished student succeeds Anna
Sanchez is a graduate of Del Sol academy
one of Clark County's Magna schools now
a senior at Nevada state a college prep
program prepared her for this so I'm a
first generation student so it was very
hard for me to find College because I
didn't know what I wanted to do Nevada
state college offers two federally
funded programs to help income eligible
first-generation college students Trio
Upward Bound focuses on students at
basic Chaparral El Dorado and Sunrise
Mountain high schools Anthony Herrera of
Nevada state consoles up to 40 students
at each school we just try to make sure
that we're there to help them so if we
know that these counselors are
overwhelmed with the caselo that they
have Kimberly Williams oversees a trio
programs at Nevada State College what
we've been able to accomplish is making
sure that 100 of our students are
graduating from high school last month
Williams launched a new program called
Trio McNair helping these first
generation college students obtain a PhD
they provide academic advising and
access to scholarships Anna Sanchez is
also part of Mcnair pursuing a PhD
degree in clinical mental health all
those resources that I had they helped
me get into college the Federal grant
for the trio McNair program is 1.3
million dollars over the next five years
reporting in Henderson Joshua peguero
eight news now